my job is
very very challenging every day you're
facing new issues you're facing new
topics
the working environment that we're in
really is unique because of its
diversity and you actually get to work
with all those people that are coming
from different countries and
it's so interesting just to be
in this multicultural environment you
know you're doing an important job
and you're doing a job that tries to
make the world a better place
actually how many people can say that
what they do
impacts the lives of more than 500
million people
you're really where the decisions are
being taken
there's a long list of things protecting
the environment
helping create jobs supporting research
and innovation
fighting poverty and promoting equal
opportunities
i was both amazed and surprised to see
the vast array of different jobs that
are actually on offer
i work with lawyers prosecutors
translators policy officers economists
scientists there's such a great offer in
terms of training that you are strongly
encouraged to learn
and grow throughout your career i could
describe my colleagues as very
professional
they are very committed they are also
having a lot of fun
i think that we do make a difference in
the lives
of not only europeans but globally
speaking
it's the opportunity of a lifetime
shall i do this one again
okay